Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number that
you can call anytime you want to chat with me.
That voicemail number is two one nine two David
Pakman. Here's a question about a sports related
political story that took place over the weekend.
Speaker 4: Hey, David, I was just wondering
what your thoughts are about the Cleveland
Indians being forced to change their name,
basically just because of a minor minority
falsely claiming racism. I mean, this is a team
whose name has been established for over
a century. And I can't believe I'm saying
this. I feel terrible saying this, but I really
agree with what Donald Trump said a while back.
This this really should not have happened.
I love to hear your thoughts about it.
Speaker 1: So listen, here's the deal, all
right? It is a very bad argument to say that
because a team has had a certain name for a long
time, it's wrong to change it. Society changes,
culture changes. And there were lots of things
that we did. It's actually it's sort of the
fundamental pillar of conservatism. Keep doing
things a certain way because we've been doing
them a certain way. Terrible argument. It's
a completely logically fallacious argument.
Here's my thought about the Cleveland Indians
changing their name to the Cleveland Guardians.
I don't really care. I don't think it's a big
deal. These are decisions that are made in a
marketplace of ideas. The team has decided they're
going to go with Cleveland guardians because
Indians is considered. You know, I don't know
that we have to use the term racist, but just
the reference to Indians in this way, combined
with the logo of the team, harkens back to
pejorative and xenophobic uses of the term. I
guess I would say that that's sort of undeniable,
whether the history and tradition overrides the
need to change it. It's not my call to make.
The people now will decide do they no longer
want to support the Cleveland Guardians because
they don't like the name? Does it reek of WOAK
culture to them such that they will protest by
no longer going to visit the Cleveland Guardians?
There's one really funny thing about this, though.
When Donald Trump started Space Force and
they announced near the end of his presidency,
you've got Marines, soldiers, all this
different stuff. The Space Force members are
going to be guardians. Everybody on the right
was cheering it and doing a standing ovation.
This is so patriotic. These are the guardians, et
cetera. And now many of the same people are saying
Guardians is lame for a baseball team. Explain to
me how if Guardians is suitable for actual members
of a branch of the armed forces who actually are
potentially someday going to be in positions of
having to defend us with weapons and all this
stuff, it's it's alpha enough for the for them,
but not for a baseball team that at the end of
the day is, you know, swinging bats and hitting
balls. It's not it's beta in that. It's just these
people are pathetic. These people are pathetic. So
I find myself mostly not caring about it, whether
it's a mistake from the standpoint of business
for the Cleveland Guardians to do this, we will
see in the future. All right. And quite frankly,
I don't care that much one way or the other
about this. There's just such such bigger issues.
I want to tell you that on today's bonus show, we
are going to talk about the new covid requirements
in France and Spain. I will soon be in one of
those countries. Am I pleased or disgusted at
what I will have to do? I will tell you on the
bonus show and much, much more get instant access
to today's bonus show by becoming a member
at Join Pakman dot com. We will see you at.